tras un muy necesitado descanso retoman
las negociaciones en la recta final de
esta conferencia climática en San melsey
cinco días quedan para ponerse de
acuerdo en el texto final que tendrán
que aprobar los casi 200 países que
forman parte del tratado climático de la
ONU creado hace 30 años un texto donde
ojalá se reflejen decisiones concretas
para implementar la reducción de
emisiones y financiar soluciones de
adaptación y mitigación pero sobre todo
para crear un mecanismo que financia las
llamadas perdidas y daños los países en
desarrollo piden que se asegure la
creación del mecanismo esta semana y que
los fondos empiecen a fluir ya en 2024 y
no que el mecanismo se cree en los
próximos dos años como está estipulado
en la agenda según estos países los
pérdidas y daños existen porque no se
actúen adaptación y mitigación en el
pasado y no se puede esperar más en unos
días llegarán los ministros para pulir
los detalles políticos del texto entre
ellos la ministra de medio ambiente de
chile que tiene un rol esencial como
facilitadora de esta cuestión polémica
de las pérdidas y daños Hoy hay dos
temas en la agenda por un lado género
que tomando como referencia la foto de
familia de la co27 que está repleta de
hombres sigue siendo una asignatura
pendiente la discusión climática y por
otro el agua tanto los impactos de su
exceso como de su escasez y Cómo mejorar
su manejo todas estas problemáticas son
según unicef problemáticas que se
podrían mejorar si estuviera incluida en
los programas educativos la educación
ambiental
crea realmente un poder de agencia de
todos los individuos de los jóvenes de
poder tener una conciencia tener
conocimiento y poder desarrollar e
implementar ideas proyectos programas
queremos que es realmente fundamental
para toda la niñez tener y contar con
estas herramientas el conocimiento
realmente
exponencial tu visión como persona y a
nivel profesional Puede crear como
nuevas industrias nuevas formas de sí de
trabajar de conocer y de relacionarnos
con este mundo natural